wow look at you see you listen
y'all got grown and sexy on this last
album
you did right and the whole world was
like okay hold on take notice
but you've also this is the first time
you've really been separated from your
sister a lot what has that been like
oh well i miss my sister every single
day she is overseas killing it i'm so
proud of her
she's doing her thing over there i'm
doing my thing over here and i can't
wait when we can come back together
your movies the georgetown project right
yes tell me about what can you tell me
about the georgetown project yes well
it was a great film i don't know when
it's going to come out but i'm excited
for more i can't wait there's a bunch of
other projects i can't wait to talk
about so
really yes i'm coming and how excited
are you for your sister i mean she is
breaking ground in the little mermaid
i am more than proud she is so beautiful
every time we facetime i get chills
because she will always be my little
mermaid and
yeah so you guys did a really cool
tribute to your dad
i love that picture that you posted to
him and he looked great
but what is him what does his support
mean to you it means the world
you know having our dad support us so
that we stand in our own confidence and
strength and power as to young black
women
and you're celebrating black women
tonight who are you celebrating
oh one i'm celebrating my mom my god mom
myself
and i can't wait to see megan and the
city girls throw it down today
so it all the women here so i'm really
excited are you gonna miss grownish
of course i am but season four premieres
i believe july 8th so
it'll be what will we get what will we
get a lot more surprises and tea
is getting more and more each season so
cannot wait i can't wait to see the
georgetown project
you